there was one hell of a football game
last night now they both were good but
the first one was great and for the
first time in the 50-year history of
monday night football there were two
lead changes in the final minute of the
game that had never happened before and
it happened last night as the new
orleans saints somehow pulled out the
victory let's get big picture reaction
to that first game starting with chris
sims your thought about the saints
pulling that victory out of the fire
against the texas well phenomenal
football game saints get off to a slow
start which is pretty status quo for
them on a week one football uh in the
nfl regular season like we've seen the
last two years but ultimately
did look like the better more complete
team
the problem and why the game was so
close though is the best player on the
field number four desean watson was
absolutely out of this world with some
of the things he pulled off in the game
which led to absolute excitement but i
think as the game went on we saw the
saints with the better team but man the
texans are dangerous with number four
and uh new orleans has got to feel good
or somewhat lucky uh that they got out
of there with with such a big win and
they got the ball back there late with
with drew brees being able to get them
back into field goal position
you know i think mike when i was
watching that game the one thing i said
was desean watson if he can play 16
games this year is going to take his
place in the pantheon
because i thought he was absolutely
terrific and under fire sacked six times
laramie tunsil was not at least in week
one the real tonic that he needed
but the other thing i found myself
thinking at the end of this game was
how valuable a good kicker is
i mean you look at the entire weekend
and you see more and more the value of a
good kicker kari vedvic basically cost
the new york jets a game
you know essentially adam vinatieri as
sacrosanct as this sounds cost the
indianapolis colts a game
and so what happens in new orleans
where we would have been talking about
the scandal of all scandals again
you know the blown call at the end of
the first half
you know where there should have been
31 seconds left on the clock for the
saints to be able to go in and get
closer to at least attempt a makeable
field goal
will lutz took their feet out of the
fire with what he did late and to me
i just think
that was a fantastic game as you said
mike but it just basically puts an
exclamation point if you've got a good
kicker he's one of the top 10 most
important players on your team
yeah you're absolutely right peter i
mean that was hardly a chip shot it was
a 58 yarder and will lutz came out and
he banged it like it would have been
good from 68 and and there was never any
doubt about it and think of how many
teams out there now
would have been panicked at the thought
of sending their kicker out it it used
to be most teams felt good about their
kickers now there is that growing
handful of teams that really would have
had very little faith in the ability of
their kicker to nail a 58 yarder with
that kind of confidence but before we
even got to that point you know once the
saints go up 27 21 and there's 50
seconds left i mean this is a long shot
for the texans right to go 75 yards and
the way they touch them
i've never seen it before two plays
right the 38-yard throw to the audrey
hopkins time on the clock
and who would have ever dreamed that
you'd leave too much time on the clock
when you get the ball back with 50
seconds left peter
yeah i mean look the one thing about
this team they're not only a deep strike
capable team
but i i said this at the time of the
trade
understand this even though maybe miami
wanted to get rid of kenny stills this
was no throw in uh who didn't mean
anything look at what happens to this
guy he has three days of practice with
deshaun watson and kenny stills comes
out and makes the play of the game at
the end of the game and really i i you
know whether they should have won it
could have won it whatever now
you look at this team they have three
legitimate threats at receiver with that
incredible catch last night by will
fuller i still think deandre hopkins is
the best wide receiver in all of
football and now imagine if your third
guy
is as reliable a player he doesn't drop
the ball kenny stills
he has a great yards per catch average
over his career and he never gets hurt
the houston texans are gonna be a load
for people down the stretch this year
yeah chris um
you had mentioned desean watson playing
as well as he did and and uh the problem
is he was in the medical tent twice
uh is he gonna make it right
and that's really the question i i know
and that's what i worry about i mean
peter makes a lot of great points
there's no doubt about it they're
dangerous with some of the speed they
have a wide receiver desean desean
watson is a good a deep ball thrower
throws a pretty deep ball as you're ever
going to see i mean it's unreal some of
the things he pulls off but man i mean
the way he plays
and mike you heard me say this last week
every play is the last play of the game
it's just always you know dancing around
scrambling hanging in there to the very
last second getting just absolutely
demolished as he's throwing the football
i don't if he continues to have to play
this style there's no way he can play 16
games there's just not we've been around
this guy this guy right guys i mean he's
not a real big guy this is not cam
newton or ben roethlisberger we're
talking about and that is like my number
one fear for the texans football team
where yes we have questions about their
defense as we saw last night because
what did i mean new orleans just picked
them apart with five and six yard passes
all night long so that was slow death
but desean watson just so much on his
plate and i really do question whether
he can physically hang in there
yeah the health of deshaun watson is an
issue and with drew brees and and look
we
we we
were treading lightly earlier when peter
was talking about adam vinatieri costing
the colts the game and we're talking
about hall of fame players here but drew
brees
i i want to go back to
a throw that was very impressive
that that made me think the game was
over at that moment that set up the
field goal to put the saints up 27-21 on
third and two from their own 15.
but
i i have to say
it should have been
31-21 thank you
27-21 right let's roll it for anybody
who's watching on tv and watch this
closely it's a great throw by drew brees
but you have to watch the ball come in
and what gin does
slows down for this ball folks if he
hits again in stride it's 31-21 and the
texans have no chance at that point and
i say this with all respect and
admiration of drew brees but this is
what happens when you're a 40 year old
quarterback chris this is what scares me
about the saints and drew brees because
other than this
every throw of the night is really just
manipulated by sean payton and i believe
this was the deepest ball he threw it
was the only ball i think he threw over
20 yards the whole night long
in the air but that is the concern and
as teams continue to play the saints and
get used to what they're trying to do on
offense this will be the big thing when
they play quality defenses in the nfl
can they back them off can they can drew
brees's arm scare them enough because we
know sean payton's got a million ways to
get alvin kamara the ball underneath
michael thomas the ball underneath i
mean everything is great that way but
ultimately we talk about this a lot
turnovers are the number one thing that
decide football games the second thing
explosive plays and i do wonder if their
pass game can deliver that way as the
season goes along and people start to
accumulate more knowledge about this
offense
well i'll just make one point about that
and mike you're absolutely right
bringing up this throw i noticed it at
the time of the throw
but let's remember this one thing and
chris you mentioned when they play a
good defense
that will be a top 12 defense in the
league uh at by the end of this year oh
i'm not sure about that defense
i think they will be i think i'm worried
a little bit about their secondary yeah
but
assuming that jj watt doesn't fall off a
cliff and he wasn't much of a factor
last night
but if jj watt is still there whitney
merciless has shown that bernard
mckinney he was great last night he was
they've got enough to be a top 12
defense in this league the only point
i'm making is this
last night drew brees as shaky as you
would think that he is he still threw
for whatever 370 yards the saints gained
510 yards last night
i'm not too worried about them i mean
and who knows that arm could become a
factor at some point this year
but let's talk about in my opinion
what you know of all the games we saw
last night i mean of all the the four
teams the units on these four teams i
would be concerned with the new orleans
defense
they've got to play better than that
they've got to get more pressure on the
quarterback than they got last night
well but they sacked him six times i
mean that's the thing is it because the
texans offensive line is bad or is the
saints defensive line better than than
maybe we expected them to be i feel like
this is more a texans thing though and i
feel like this is going to be the theme
of the season just like it was last year
you pick up laramie tonsil that
addresses one out of five spots all it
takes is one glaring weakness on your
offensive line chris and your
quarterback's running for his life all
day yes and it's still it's still early
too just like what peter's saying i mean
their o-line still kind of getting back
getting together as far as cohesiveness
and getting everybody on the same page
there is something to that i mean you
get a franchise left tackle who's only
been there for a week he and he did it
looked like he messed up a few times
last night i think there's two other
things at play here just off to what
what peter said first off i i don't
think that the texans have enough easy
completions for deshaun watson every
player stand in the pocket wait for six
seconds dance around i hope somebody's
open 30 yards downfield i mean you know
can we throw some screen passes some
more quick passes to get the ball out of
his hand to save him that way the other
thing as far as the saints point the
saints play way too much man-to-man i
mean just even there what you saw at the
end of the football football game you
know why why are we even playing
press bump man to man with a great
corner and marshawn lattimore against
deandre hopkins with 50 seconds left in
the game why i mean yeah is it just a
it's stone cold oh we got marshawn
lattimore over there he's our best
corner he'll shut him down oh yeah well
i mean as peter said deandre hopkins in
the conversation for the best wide
receiver in football that would be my
other issue with the saints over
aggressive in the coverage too much too
many one-on-one shots and we saw that's
what they went down the field boom boom
and it was man-to-man and deshawn put it
right on the money
that's a great point you're defending
the end zone from 75 yards away with 50
seconds
i don't care if you have leon sanders
let's help him out a little bit that's
my point you just play just just drop
into deep coverage give him a 20-yard
completion a field goal isn't going to
matter right peter it really is stunning
that it even got to the point where the
texans scored and scored his qu
surely the plan wasn't let him score
quickly and we'll go down the field and
pick a 58-yard field goal but but what
do you do what are you doing if you're
the saints giving up that much territory
that quickly peter
i i think you're right mike i think
especially when you have a guy as
competitive and tough and excellent in
man coverage as a guy like marshawn
lattimore is
i think there was way too much cushion
given by dennis allen and his defense at
times in that game and if you are
getting the pressure that you're getting
that they got at times and i think it
was an at times situation then i would
have i would have
really ratcheted up the coverage it's
like you know the jets i watched the
jets game on sunday and tremaine johnson
is playing like 18 yards off what
position is that it's like he's a
deep safety playing corner you know
because i think they have a fear that
he's he's afraid of getting beat over
the top
but the saints should not have that same
fear that's a good secondary right there
and i think they got to be playing
closer to the line of scrimmage
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports